Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Scientists at the Seoul National University
in South Korea wrote a great paper on teaching
an imaginary dragon all kinds of really cool
aerobatic maneuvers, like sharp turning, rapid
winding, rolling, soaring, and diving.
This is all done by a reinforcement learning
variant, where the problem formulation is
that the AI has to continuously choose the
character’s actions to maximize a reward.
Here, this reward function is related to a
trajectory which we can draw in advance, these
are the lines that the dragon seems follow
quite well.
However, what you see here is the finished
product.
Curious to see how the dragon falters as it
learns to maneuver properly?
Well, we are in luck.
Buckle up.
You see the ideal trajectory here with black,
and initially, the dragon was too clumsy to
navigate in a way that even resembles this
path.
Then, later, it learned to start the first
turn properly, but as you see here, it was
unable to avoid the obstacle and likely needs
to fly to the emergency room.
But it would probably miss that building too,
of course.
After more learning, it was able to finish
the first loop, but was still too inaccurate
to perform the second.
And finally, at last, it became adept at performing
this difficult maneuver.
Applause!
One of the main difficulties of this problem
is the fact that the dragon is always in motion
and has a lot of momentum, and anything we
do always has an effect later, and we not
only have to find one good action, but whole
sequences of actions that will lead us to
victory.
This is quite difficult.
So how do we do that?
To accomplish this, this work not only uses
a reinforcement learning variant, but also
adds something called self-regulated learning
to it, where we don’t present the AI with
a fixed curriculum, but we put the learner
in charge of its own learning.
This also means that it is able to take a
big, complex goal and subdivide it into new,
smaller goals.
In this case, the big goal is following the
trajectory with some more additional constraints,
which, by itself, turned out to be too difficult
to learn with these traditional techniques.
Instead, the agent realizes, that if it tracks
its own progress on a set of separate, but
smaller subgoals, such as tracking its own
orientation, positions, and rotations against
the desired target states separately, it can
finally learn to perform these amazing stunts.
That sounds great, but how is this done exactly?
This is done through a series of three steps,
where step one is generation, where the learner
creates a few alternative solutions for itself
and proceeds to the second step, evaluation,
where it has to judge these individual alternatives
and find the best ones.
And third, learning, which means looking back
and recording whether these judgments indeed
put the learner in a better position.
By iterating these three steps, this virtual
dragon learned to fly properly.
Isn’t this amazing?
I mentioned earlier that this kind of problem
formulation is intractable without self-regulated
learning, and you can see here how a previous
work fares on following these trajectories.
There is indeed a world of a difference between
the two.
So there you go, in case you enter a virtual
world where you need to train your own dragon,
you’ll know what to do.
But just in case, also read the paper in the
video description!
If you enjoyed this episode and you wish to
watch our other videos in early access, or
get your name immortalized in the video description,
please consider supporting us on Patreon through
Patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers.
The link is available in the video description,
and this way, we can make better videos for
you.
We also support cryptocurrencies, the addresses
are also available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!